portico security specializing cash
trucks across la
do you have any idea how dangerous this
job can be
somehow dave yeah we ain't the predators
we're the prey
you ready ready you know you've been
working working with guy
all the way back since lock stock and
two smoking barrels
curious to know how how you see him
has having evolved as a filmmaker in all
that time and
how has your collaboration together
evolved in the years since
uh you know it's uh it's been a long old
journey i mean it's 20 years now plus
since we were kicking around and we look
back and see ourselves and we recognize
how
how we've aged so much um but you know
we
we've still kept this same sort of
youthful
stupidity that we bring to the working
day
and i think i think you know if we
didn't enjoy ourselves as much as we did
we wouldn't i i don't think we would
have sort of
succeeded like we had and you know we
got very lucky
we did a couple of movies back in the
day that just seemed to catch people's
eye and
you know it really paved the way for me
to to make a career out of it
um so you know we've been circling
i mean we the fact that i've been out in
the u.s for so long
means that we haven't sort of aligned as
much as we could have done
but you know we're we're back on the set
together we
you know we it's been probably 15 years
since the last one i did
revolver um and it just feels like we
never stop
it's um it's just that great onset sort
of buzz that he creates
everybody's just you know enjoying their
day's work
yeah was there a new technique or a type
of training
that you had to learn in order to make
this
look real no because you kind of go for
the ride with guy and i think
the script is uh something that evolves
as the day
starts you know he has things that he
wants to bring
and new new words of dialogue that
impact the next scene that we're going
to shoot tomorrow
and i think it's all an organic kind of
mess
on the face of it and you think you know
you have to be quite
unattached as they say to your dialogue
you have to be unattached
to what happens in the story because
it's
you know it's almost like a bobbling
problem things that he likes to change
and i think
i think it's this intuitive
sort of knowledge that he's uh you know
developed over the years that
he just knows how to sharpen the knife
as we go along
and i think for the you know for the
action alone
you know i wasn't i wasn't allowed to
sort of bring any kind of
pre-rehearsed kind of hong kong
style actually it's just what he didn't
want yeah yeah
you know uh one of the things i love
about this film is i'm gonna go see it
again
uh on the big screen um you know how
how why is the movie theater experience
important to you and how has it impacted
your life over the years ah the movie
yes
you know it's just a great place and you
it's
you know i i have the best memories of
seeing
movies that uh have made an impression
upon me
just the whole experience is it's not
the same sitting on your sofa
uh and watching the movie like it is to
going out
and you know being in the surround sound
and the you know the
100 foot screen it's just not the same
thing
uh i i'm so i'm just waiting for it to
all be back to where it was
a while back we lost two cars a civilian
too
there was an investigation they still
haven't found a scum who did it you know
guy richie's been making crime movies
for over 20 years now he's like a master
of that genre uh having now worked with
him on wrath of man what do you think he
brings to these kinds of movies that
really separates him from
other other directors other filmmakers
that make crime films
he he has
i think impeccable taste and
knows what's cool and what isn't
and he
does you know is bold and makes choices
that
you'd never even think about you know
you see a film
or you think oh you know this this will
be cool and then you see what he does
and
he just takes it so far past what what
you even could
think in your head so he like you said
he's a master
was there anything specific that you had
to learn
uh in order you know any kind of
training technique or
you know something that you didn't know
how to do before that you had to learn
for this film
not specifically um this was this this
character i played was was
you know he was sort of an unhinged
character he was
a character who uh isn't afraid to
take what he wants when he wants it so i
think
it was it was just more about developing
the character and
and bringing in
bringing something different you know a
character that i hadn't played before
yeah you know i i'm fascinated by the
world of armored cars in this film you
don't really kind of see movies about
armored car heists as much uh was there
anything you learned about armored cars
or the world
uh that maybe the general public isn't
necessarily aware of
i think the amount of cash
uh i always pictured an armored car
you know taking not that much money
around but there's so much cash that
changes hands between
banks and small businesses and
medium-sized businesses that
i think i was blown away that there
really has to be
these safeguards and these in these
vaults and and they are vulnerable in
some
in some respects to to being you know to
being hijacked
yeah you know scott i'm a big champion
of the movie theater experience i'm
gonna go back and see this again in a
movie theater
uh what's your favorite thing about
going to the movies
look i mean movie theaters are magic
they're they really are they they
immerse you
they they suspend your disbelief
it's the way film is meant to be seen
it's why we go and we spend months
filming it we
do it with such scope and
this movie is meant to be seen in
theaters and the theater experience is
is what uh made me fall in love with
filmmaking and and being a part of film
and i hope people go and see it
in the theater doesn't feel right
[Music]
it's like he wants trucks to get hit
he's not a cop but if he's not a cop
what is he
you know you've been making uh movies or
at least you've been you know you made a
movie with jason
1998 so over 20 years now you guys have
been collaborating
uh how has your relationship with jason
matured
or changed since you're since those
early days those early team-ups
it's funny someone showed me a picture
of uh here and i
when we were i i just made another film
with him actually a couple of months ago
and we were in turkey and someone took a
photo
of what we look like in 98 and what we
look like
whatever year we're in now jason has an
age of day
and i put on i put on about 60 pounds
there and that was really the only
difference uh
other than that uh you know there's 22
years of
life uh under that bridge
and uh he's just become a very dear
friend and it's rather convenient that
he's become a movie star too
yeah you know what do you think makes a
crime movie
timeless um i think it's the genre that
there are certain
genres of movie that are just
classically
uh enduring and it's a good question and
there's just not a lot of
revenge is one of those genres i mean
the movie as it transpires which by the
way i only saw it you know
in his full manifestation a couple of
weeks ago with jason and what we were
surprised about is that it was a heist
movie but it's a revenge movie and i'm
not quite sure which one he is
it's both um and i think when we set out
it was a revenge movie but actually you
get
beguiled by the the heist of it all so
uh we got we got two for the price of
one there
what what i mean in terms of the genre i
mean where do you see it going like are
there any new places in the coming years
you know with everything that's
happening in the world or what have you
where you could see the crime genre sort
of evolving to a next level
uh where you could see the war genre the
crime
genre yeah i mean
in the end if if crime is not
accessible and exciting and so often
crime is not
incidentally uh and the real money
is in unexciting crime is the truth
but it in order to make it uh
interesting it needs to be visceral yeah
yeah
um
is there anything specific that you
would like to explore
going forward that you haven't done yet
that you're you're oh yeah yeah i'm sure
i'm sure there is i mean in part you
know i
made this because i haven't visited uh
the revenge genre
um and to to make something as
as stone cold as this is um
i usually inject some degree of humor
which i had to
work quite hard against injecting into
this one
so i'm i i very much like playing with
different genres
uh for all sorts of reasons but yeah i
mean
you know i didn't think i was going to
end up in family entertainment as in
as in aladdin before i started having to
go but
you know i love that uh but it was quite
nice to
i mean this followed hot in the heels of
that i believe oh no there was a
gentleman was in between there
so no it's fun to uh it's fun to mix up
genres as a director
you